well you scared the whole internet
because
you archived every photo of randall what
is going on
i'm going to be so real right now with
you bryce
because it's so petty it's so petty that
you're going to die
first off why aren't you together what's
happening
where are we i came to utah to hang out
with my mom and my brother and just get
some
you know utah back in my blood for a
moment
okay we're revisiting lauren yes exactly
we're going back to lauren birmingham
for a hot second
[Laughter]
and randall you are back in la right
yeah i mean we have been on
the road for five weeks together in
puerto rico florida north carolina and
we came back to la together
and she wanted to go uh you know why i
work now
back in the office she wanted to take a
few days and and go see all of her
family and friends
yeah i've been keeping up with your
quarantine you guys have had
quite the adventurous time while we're
all in lockdown
i think you've been safe everywhere
you've gone but you've seen a lot of
places
puerto rico is where you were shooting
the movie right correct
and did you get to finish the movie we
didn't finish
we actually moved the film
to california and our finishing first
week in september
in san yanez now i would say
about 35 is completed and
60 you know 65 will finish
but during this whole time you guys have
not stopped podcasting
what have you learned about each other
from the podcast oh
that's a tough question i've learned
that randall really enjoys talking over
me
we're trying to curb that but also i've
learned on
the positive side he is really great at
asking amazing questions to our guests i
had no idea that he
had the talent of interviewing people
i've known that he was a great
producer and director but to watch him
carry on great interviews is really
incredible to see
thank you han you're welcome did you
know you had that skill randall
i didn't no no i'm very intrigued by
people
so i think that maybe that comes out as
she's saying with the questions and
stuff
so i've had a really good time doing it
and have you learned anything about lala
from doing this with her
oh you got a few minutes no uh
no i mean i i love working with her i i
you know i i we're we're best friends
and we're lovers and
i think when we do this podcast i don't
really get to see the business side of
la la
she's very professional and very
diligent
with the podcast so what i've learned
about lala is she really is a little ceo
who is a boss and she bosses me around
in the podcast but in the best way i've
learned
that you you want to be prepared
otherwise
well people thought you were getting the
wrath of lala a couple weeks ago
well you scared the whole internet
because
you archived every photo of randall what
is it going on
i didn't even know this existed i mean
we're we're on vacation we're in marco
island
we have a little tint like any couple
it's a tiff
you keep calling a tick tiff
whatever a tiff a tad whatever it is
i'm gonna be so real right now with you
bryce what happened was
we went to the grocery store and we got
so much food
and as we were checking out i would
wheel out
because it's so petty it's so petty that
you're gonna die
so i as he's checking out just sitting
there really
i'm wheeling the carts out and filling
the car up so that we don't have four
carts to load at once
then we go back to the house and i
unload all the groceries he goes m.i.a
not only do i unload the groceries
i put them away this guy i go
m.i.a i went water on a boat
water skiing i was so pissed bryce i was
like
if you wanted a housewife to cook and
clean you got the wrong
girl you got the wrong one so i archived
because i was petty i was just petty
like hold on it's so stupid it's so
stupid
we didn't need to tell that story second
of all
i did price i did buy like
1500 worth of groceries i went a little
crazy and i didn't think i was so
excited to get back on the boat
and then i my phone started blowing up
and she was a little perturbed
but here's the thing i didn't even know
you could archive somebody's photos so i
was like
whatever i apologize
i unloaded the groceries with her and we
moved on hold on
hold on and then i start getting texts
from friends of mine
around the country going i hope you're
okay
i go well i'm great i'm in marco island
we're water speeding
no you broke up with walls i go what so
i don't even know what they're talking
about
and then i i google to see
and i'm like lala what did you do she's
like i
archived all your photos i didn't even
know i may i may or may not have been
pmsing that day yeah
i mean it seems like no one's in the
right here
no it was so stupid it was so stupid
bryce like i couldn't believe
that people were even well because they
took the
fourth step prayer that i had posted i
was
feeling very i get into these zones of
really
wanting to kind of i don't want to say
preach but preach about sobriety and how
it's
changed my life so people didn't realize
that if you went three days
before that i started with the first
step second step third and that just
happened to fall on the fourth step
prayer where i archived all of randall's
photos so you put
both of them together and it did look
messy right people like lala's cryptic
post
and then but if you google it and
immediately pump like every aaa website
in america pops up
when i saw the article the articles that
have come out i'm like
what is going on i want to think that
i'm going to grow out of my pettiness
but i'm telling you when it's that time
of the month
it is like i'm just a dragon
how long does it take to archive all
those photos
yeah how long does it take well because
i'm a professional at it
it takes like a minute quick
easy and it takes the same amount of
time to add them back
i'm a professional but you guys also
don't follow each other on instagram and
never have right
never yeah we once when we got together
we blocked each other on instagram and
and not even because we were like
fighting we had just seen
so many couples like and are you eating
mcdonald's
randall you're supposed to be on a diet
i am on a diet
the mickey mouse mickey d's diet i just
played pickleball for two hours this
morning
all right all right all right okay you
can have your mcdonald's
we had seen so many relationships that
got
crazy because of social media like they
would see like someone liked your
picture whatever it may be and so we
just blocked each other
from the jump and yeah but if it's not
broken don't fix it
no we did it kind of good like as a goof
early on in our relationship
and we just like all right we won't
follow each other and we never changed
it and then i always see these articles
that come out she'll show me or
i'll see them and it'll say they
unfollowed each other it's like we never
follow each other from day one it's all
so stupid i can't even believe that i
did that and fed into the nonsense well
because then it took you
a moment to clear the air
so like you let that the story have its
life too
i did you lala let the story have its
life i feel like it had a 24 hour
no one knew what was going on and then
yeah
you but you also have to i don't feel
like it was even about this
it having life we were in a place that
was
really amazing and i just didn't think
about correcting it it was like okay i'm
over the pettiness now
i can just go and move on no you were
over that 30 minutes the the grocery
thing
i don't know that randall you posted a
picture of lala with your girls right
after that too was that
like your message of this everything's
fine or was that just
so hard bryce to set the record straight
no
okay don't promote yourself so much
what happened was a lot of my friends
were blowing me up
and i go well what did you do that i
have to answer all these questions
so i just put up a picture so it was
really for my friends
so they knew that everything was kosher
wasn't even like i was trying to tell
anybody beyond
the 36 of my friends that were like are
you okay
they're calling me i'm like i'm fine
they were like i'm so sorry i'm really
sorry
ran and i'm like guys we are fine
i didn't put the damn groceries away
enough already
that is funny uh but lala with the
posting of the fourth step prayer you
are approaching
two years of sobriety correct yeah yes
it's october congratulations
um has the whole quarantine lockdown
made things difficult or made you have
any moments of weakness
i would be lying if i said there wasn't
a chunk of time where i was fixated
on the minibar in the hotel room and
you know i use the tools that i've you
know learned in
aaa which is call my sponsor find a
meeting
and drop to my knees and pray and ask
for
the the craving to go away i know that
this is something i will never be able
to conquer
it will always be inside of me there's
going to be times where i'm going to
have to work
a little bit harder or a lot a bit
harder as long as i can
i can disengage from my thought process
and call my sponsor i think i'll be okay
but but i know i'll never conquer the
disease
it's a very humbling thing to go through
because
i am a conqueror and unfortunately
when you choose a life of sobriety you
don't have control you have to have
help in my experience so
yeah it's something i love the life that
i'm living and i'm i'm not willing to
give my chair up for anybody so
i will continue to to work hard at it
another uh wrench that this pandemic
threw
was your wedding was supposed to happen
in april what's going on
oh you tell us i know right
we we had planned to get married instead
of
april and then we pushed it back to
september
and then i had a phone call with my
wedding planner and she said i want to
be very transparent with you what this
wedding will look like if you choose to
do it
in september and i just said you know
my heart is set on something very
beautiful i don't want to look back on
my
wedding pictures and see everyone in
masks and i'm not saying that people
that are getting married
in this situation right now should look
at their pictures and
feel like their weddings are tainted but
randall and i had a rocky start at the
beginning of our relationship
i want the wedding to be like a brand
new day for us
like the the beginning to something
amazing so i
convinced him to switch it to next year
okay 2021 yeah it's just
to do anything that we have planned
will not happen this year it's zero
bryce they said
no dance floor uh no cocktail hour
no open bar uh six feet apart with uh
chairs and by the way we know you have a
guest list of upwards of 200 people
you're only gonna have 50.
right it just it just wasn't going to
work so she sat down with me
again it was an emotion we cried we
cried all right you questioned
us you cried have you thought about
though like eloping making the
commitment for yourselves and then
having the big party later
we did we we both talked about that and
we were
we were pretty close to doing it and
then we both had talked it through
calmly like okay let's think about this
we're basically married we look at each
other as married already
and do we want to have that big magical
day and have that moment
be authentic in that day or do we just
want to say
screw it we'll just have some big party
down the line
and i let lala really make that decision
ultimately and
she decided to but we want to keep the
big wedding
and the magical day because we we put a
lot of our heart and soul into planning
it
lala you did make a commitment step
though you are now branded with rand
can you believe it i am i'm branded with
rand on
my my bicep there's not much there but
i i had picked this font and
i was like it's perfect and i
i got tattooed with um megan and coulson
when we were in puerto rico
and they were like we will not allow you
to get such a generic
font for the person you love sit down
and you're going to
write his name until you have the
perfect font
and so that's what i did it's my it's my
handwriting well hold on and let me take
it away and it's my new favorite tattoo
oh let me take it a step further so
we're sitting there
in in uh puerto rico and they're like
we're gonna
all get tattoos of our significant other
and i'm like whoa whoa whoa i
am old i am not getting a tattoo
i am not cool like you coulson or megan
fox or lawa
so they all did their tattoos and it was
honestly it was very very sweet and
romantic
you know all being there together and it
was it was really
it was really sweet and and very and it
was very emotional that
lala did that because i had no idea she
was gonna do that i thought it was
megan and and coulson getting a tattoo i
didn't know lala was throwing in the
ramp
here's the thing anyone can any chick
can walk around with a diamond on their
finger and be like oh i'm engaged i'm so
down for him
it takes a real one to walk out of the
house with his
name tattooed on you now that is
commitment
wait but are you saying that megan and
coulson got tattoos for each other
randall you spill too much tea bro i did
don't spill so much tea bruh
am i in trouble you're not no okay
i think that might be yeah right oh
bryce look at you try to swindle
what tattoos did they get where did they
get done i don't know
i don't know i don't know i just thought
i got they got tattoos that's all i know
i'm not good at this take it back to
your wedding have you reevaluated
if you want to do it on tv or not i'm
not opposed to it
but then when i really think about it b
i'm like i don't want people judging
my wedding day like there's very few
things
that i care about being judged where i'm
like
whatever my wedding day is one where
like i don't want people to have their
right to give their opinion on what it
was like
and there's the whole breaking the
fourth wall thing of like having to film
scenes at your wedding
yes i don't want to do that i want to
just have fun
i don't want them to turn my music off
because it's not
they can't get the rights to it right
buzzkill
but speaking of tv do we know what's
going on with vanderpump rules are we
coming back
are we waiting this thing out what's
happening you know it's
really just the whole situation
is so sad for so many people this virus
and you know people are
losing their jobs or not going back to
work and
our show is based on a restaurant and
there's no plan to open those
restaurants anytime soon so
we're just as in the dark as everybody
else the main goal is to keep everybody
healthy
so as long as we're doing that like i'm
ready
whenever they're ready and yeah i have
no idea what
what the future holds as far as the
start date when that
day comes things are going to be
different stassi and kristen are no
longer part of the show
i said this the other day and people
thought it was very odd but you almost
feel this weird loss
and i want to say that it hasn't sunk in
yet because it hasn't we haven't started
filming so i don't know what it's going
to be like
but it does feel like a little part of
me is
missing because we've been we have so
much history
good and bad and we've been through a
lot together so
you know i it just still hasn't fully
hit me yet
it'll be i think interesting probably
for you guys and then for the viewers to
see how it
is addressed on screen and then how the
movement at large how black lives matter
is addressed on screen do you have any
idea how how the group might
approach those topics yeah um
black lives matter since this
movement started has always been near
and dear to my heart
um i like to say that i'm educated but i
don't think we could ever be educated
enough
so i my main thing is when we do start
filming i don't want to
speak for someone else i don't think
it's right for me to
be a mouthpiece for kristin or stassi
i'm steering clear of that i i don't
feel right about
talking for someone else when they're
not there to
to actually describe their thoughts and
their process
your name did get tossed around in all
that kind of
drama that happened it did seem like you
were able to touch base
with faith and all this and kind of have
a conversation right
yeah you know she reached out to me
about my dad passing away
so that was how the the line of
communication was opened
and then after hearing how she left the
show
i never want anyone to leave vanderpump
rules with a pit in their stomach
because i know that feeling and so i
really just called
to to apologize
for for sending her off with with that
feeling
and you know she was very receptive if
you watch the season
for you know all those episodes faith
and i were
thick we were like she was my best
friend we we had sleepovers every single
night like that was my
girl and then when things went south you
know
she's like me she's a runner you know i
did that too
when things got hot for me i ran back to
utah and
she did the same type of thing so i can
understand that
but it was when she reached out to me
about my dad
that was like when anybody i don't care
what
we've been through if you reached out to
me about my dad our slate was clean and
we could start from square one
she has said that she would be open to
returning to the show
would you want to see her come be a cast
member
she is so much fun we've had great times
together
so i'm not opposed to it at all if
if they called tomorrow and said faith
is coming back i think a lot of us would
welcome her with open arms there's a lot
of things that have happened but
if you've seen vanderpump rules we've
done a lot of shady things with each
other and we all bounce back from them
this is true this is true there is also
another vanderpump show coming
vanderpump dogs do you know anything
about what that show's gonna be
i have no idea i'm assuming that it's
going to be about all of the fabulous
volunteers and workers at
the the shelter and everything lisa
vanderpump touches turns to you know
rose and diamond
so i'm sure i'll be watching because i'm
a sucker for all things vanderpump
and i'm a sucker for dogs so the perfect
combo
what do you make of all the criticism
lisa's gotten all of this people saying
shouldn't support the movement of black
lives matter she doesn't support black
people
when what's on the show is she's not the
end-all be-all of what makes it to tv
no she's not the end-all be-all at all
actually i think if if she was we would
have a very different
show i haven't seen any type of
hate or ill will for any specific
race or gender or sexuality when it
comes to
lisa vanderpump um but
again you know i think people have to
speak for themselves
i don't want people speaking for me on
something like this so i
i'm not going to speak for anybody else
there it is
there it is all right randall you know i
have to get in a couple
megan coulson questions because you are
the matchmaker that we didn't know what
our world needed
you have created the power couple of the
pandemic
did you know this was going to happen
did you see sparks flying from the
second they were on set
when i was watching when i was directing
them uh in those two days the first two
days together
you know it was there was a lot of
sparks
in the sense of like the chemistry and
and they definitely were in tune in the
scene
but i didn't know that that was gonna
lead to anything
and all of a sudden it's like they're a
couple
i definitely take credit thank you very
much uh
but you know i didn't really see it when
i was on set at all because it was very
professional
there was that the chemistry was second
to none
but i just thought i'm a great director
and
i'm a genius uh but i didn't know that
there were these undertones and all that
and then
uh and now we've spent a lot of time
with them
uh since they've been together and it's
really sweet and beautiful and
i'm very happy for both of them and they
they really are
uh very passionate people and passionate
about each other
i mean only 35 of a movie done in
already the film has a legacy
so hey it's so you know
neil hurst said that to me the other day
he goes movies can't even get half this
publicity when they're released
let alone holy shot 35
well and then the podcast interview you
guys did was so great and they were so
open and shared so much yeah i i really
was grateful so is lala we sat there
we didn't even know colson was going to
be part of it it was like
you know megan's big in astrology and
and and readings and so she was excited
to do it
and colson's like hey i'm i also want to
be in on this
this will be fun and i was like okay and
it's like the four of us hanging out
i just i you know i'm not as like savvy
with
i don't know the t so to speak this
feeling of the teeth
yeah but uh boy i guess that that
podcast people really uh
liked a lot well with with our podcast
and something that i
i do pride the podcast on is
we want our guests to feel safe if
there's something that they talk about
and they think that you know they
they get a little too free i will allow
them the opportunity
to say i spoke too freely can we cut
that out because i know what it's like
to feel a little too comfortable and
start
spilling a little too much tea and then
it's everywhere
i told her i'm gonna send you this
episode i want you to listen to it
before we put it out and
she gave full approval and said i i love
everything about it
send it out she is so genuine and so
sincere and
so fun and so just loves life and i
think that that comes out
you know for anybody who interviews her
but also
for us as friends and in her circle
she's uh very sweet and
and genuine i mean the podcast gave us a
eye into it but like to be a fly on the
wall for your
double dates and the vacation i would
let me let me tell you let me tell you
the joke i make about our double dates
okay
and they know i say this to their face
going on a double date with megan and
coulson the first half
is very double date everybody's
conversing we're having fun we're
laughing
the second half they don't even know our
name they're distributing to each other
so lala and they're like okay it's our
date time now no
it's very sweet it's very sweet of
course but i mean come on
i told cole so you don't even know my
name the second half of the day
i mean give him credit megan fox is
sitting in front of him what do you want
him to do
what do you want him to do not not at
all it's their fun
it's we laugh and and they they don't
take themselves
as serious you know as people would
think but they ver but they they're very
passionate about one another very happy
and
uh i mean it's really sweet to to see
that
i had a little hand in in there yeah
randall loves that
oh my god
first movie he's directing a major like
national news story comes out of it you
got to let him have a moment with it
i will always allow his moment have it
have it baby
i don't know maybe 20 21 double wedding
oh my gosh could you imagine wow
i'm putting it out there it's so funny
because
i've i've been very open about uh
randall and i wanting to have a baby and
we've been trying
and i told megan and megan said i i'm
gonna be your doula just so you know
like the second you get pregnant
like be prepared i am your doula so
that's pretty gangster that
megan fox is gonna be my doula when i
get knocked up that is a badass and i
feel like she's gonna be a
kick ass dude yeah oh for sure
she'll be reading that baby's chart from
inside the womb it's gonna be a whole
thing
it'll be a whole thing it'll be awesome